let's do a little compare and contrast
between the dot product and the cross
product so let me just
make two vectors just let me visually
draw them and maybe if we have time
we'll actually
figure out now that's too thin
we'll actually figure out some dot and
cross products with real vectors
and
let me make another one
i always make a relatively acute angle
maybe i'll make an up
well uh
i'll always do the acute angle
okay
let's call
the first one
let me just label them
take forever if i keep
switching colors
that's the angle between them
okay so let's just go over the
definitions and then we'll work on the
intuition and hopefully you have a
little bit of both already so what does
a
dot be
that
well first of all that's the exact same
thing as b
dot a order does not matter when you
take the dot product because you you end
up with just a number
and that is equal to the magnitude of a
times the magnitude of b
times cosine
of the angle between them
fair enough let's look at the definition
of the cross product what is
a
cross
b
well first of all that does not equal b
cross a it actually equals the the
opposite direction or you could view it
as the negative of b cross a because the
vector that you end up with ends up
flipped whichever order you do it in but
a cross b that is equal to
the magnitude
of vector a
times the magnitude of vector b so far
it looks a lot like the dot product but
this is where the diverges times the
sine of the angle between them
the sine of the angle between them and
this is where it really diverges right
this when we took the dot product we
just ended up with a number this is just
a number there's no direction here this
is just a scalar quantity but the cross
product we take the magnitude of a times
the magnitude of b times the sine of the
angle between them and that provides the
magnitude it also has a direction and
the direction is provided by this normal
vector which i'll just it's a unit
vector
the unit vector gets that little hat on
it
it's a unit vector and what direction is
it well that's defined by the right hand
rule it's a it's a this is a vector
it's
it's perpendicular so perpendicular
perpendicular
to both
a and b
and then well you might say okay a and b
the way i drew them they're both sitting
in the plane of this video screen or
your video screen so in order for
something to be perpendicular to both of
these it either has to pop out of the
screen or pop into the screen right and
when you learned about the cross product
i said you know there's two ways of you
know to show a vector popping out of the
screen it looks like that because that's
the tip of an arrow and to show a vector
going into the screen it's like that
because that is a
the back of an arrow the rear end of an
arrow
so how do you know which of these two it
is because both of these vectors are
perpendicular to a and b well that's
where you take your let your right hand
and you use the right hand rule so you
take your index finger in the direction
of a
your middle finger in the direction of b
and then your thumb points in the pr
the direction of n so let's do that i'm
looking at my hand
and it looks like it's actually not an
easy thing to do with your right hand
but your right hand is going to look
something like this
your
index finger is going to well
let me actually do it in the direction
of a
so your index finger will go in the
direction of a
your middle finger goes in the direction
of b
so that's my middle finger
and then my other two fingers just do
what they need to do i like to just bend
them out of the way
i'm trying my best to draw
so they just curl around my hand
and then what direction is my thumb in
my thumb well actually i do it in the
wrong angle i do it my thumb is actually
going in this direction
right into the page
this is the top of my hand these are
like my veins
right or if i actually drew it correctly
where it would actually you would see it
you would see your hand from the side so
it would look like this
you would see your pinky you'd see like
your palm and your pinky would be like
that
then your other finger like this your
middle finger would go in the direction
of b
your index finger goes in the direction
of a and you actually wouldn't even see
your thumb because your thumb is
pointing straight down but i think you
get the point a cross b this n vector is
pointing straight down it's a unit
vector and this provides the magnitude
unit vector just means it has a
magnitude of 1. so
the magnitudes of the cross and the dot
product seem pretty close they both have
the magnitudes of both vectors there
dot product cosine theta
cross product sine of theta but then the
huge difference is that sine of theta
has a direction it is a different vector
that is perpendicular to both of these
now let's get the intuition and if
you've watched the videos on the dot and
the cross product hopefully you have a
little intuition but i'll review it
because i think it all fits together
when you see them
with each other
let me
do some erasing no that's not what i
wanted to do
nope that's not what i want to do
i could erase this way
okay
so first let's study with a b cosine of
theta so if you watch the dot product
video cosine of theta when you take if
you took let's say b cosine of theta
what is b cosine of theta
b cosine of theta and you can work it
out on your own time if you say cosine
is adjacent over hypotenuse b cosine of
theta is actually going the magnitude of
b cosine theta is actually going to be
the magnitude as if you dropped a
perpendicular i'll do a different color
here
if you dropped a perpendicular here
this length right here that's b cosine
theta let me draw it separately i don't
want to mess up this picture too much so
if that's b
now i'll get the same a
no i was going to use a line tool
if that's
a and now the rest of it i'll just doing
one color to save time
and that's b
that's a
this is theta b cosine theta is if you
drop a pop a line perpendicular to a
this is right angle
b cosine theta adjacent over hypotenuse
is equal to cosine theta so it'd be the
projection of b going in the same
direction as a
so it would
it would be this magnitude
that is b cosine theta
so the mag
the magnitude of that
vector right there is b
the magnitude of b
cosine of theta
so when you're taking the dot product at
least the example i just did it when you
if you say if you view it as the
magnitude of a times the magnitude of b
cosine theta you're saying what part of
b goes in the same direction as a
and whatever that magnitude is let me
just multiply that times the magnitude
of a and i have the dot product so how
let's take the pieces that go in the
same direction and multiply them so how
much do they move together or do they
point to get together or you could view
it the other way you could view the dot
product as and i did this in the dot
product video you could view it as a
cosine of theta b
right because it doesn't matter these
are all scalar quantities so it doesn't
matter what order you you take the
multiplication in and a cosine theta is
the same thing it's the magnitude of the
a vector that's going in the same
direction as b or the projection of a
onto b
so this vector right here
is a cosine theta the magnitude of a
cosine theta
and they're actually the same number if
you take how much of b goes in the
direction of a and multiply that with
the magnitude of a that gives you the
same number as how much of a goes in the
direction of b and then take and take
the uh and then multiply the two
magnitudes
now what is a b sine theta
a b sine theta well if this
vector right here is a cosine theta
and you learned this when you learned
how to take the components of vectors
this vector right here
is the magnitude of a sine theta
right you could rewrite this as the
magnitude of a
sine theta
times the magnitude of b
in that normal vector direction
so if you take a sine theta times b
you're saying what part of a doesn't go
in the same direction as b what part of
a is completely perpendicular to b has
nothing to do with b they share nothing
in common it goes it goes in a
completely different direction that's a
sine theta and so you take the product
of this with b and then you get a third
vector and it almost says how different
are these two vectors and it points in a
different direction it kind of gives you
this sometimes it's called a pseudo
vector because it applies to some
concepts that are pseudo-vectors but the
most important of these concepts is
torque when we talk about the magnetic
field
the the the force of a magnetic field on
electric charge these are all
forces or these are all physical
phenomenon where what matters isn't the
direction of the force
with another vector it's the direction
of the force perpendicular to another
vector and so that's where the cross
product comes in useful anyway
hopefully that gave you a little
intuition and you could have done it the
other way you could have written this as
b sine theta and then you would say oh
well that's the component of b that is
perpendicular to a so b sine theta
actually would have been
this vector
right or let me draw it here that'd make
more sense this is this would be b sine
theta
so you you could you know you could
switch orders you could visualize it
either way you could say this is the
magnitude of b that's completely
perpendicular to a you multiply the two
and use the right hand rule to get that
normal vector and that right hand rule
there's nothing we just decided you know
that we're going to use the right-hand
rule to have a common convention but
people could have used the left-hand
rule or they might have used it a
different way it's just a way that we
have a consistent
framework so when we take the cross
product we all know what direction that
normal vector is pointing in anyway in
the next video i'll show you how to
actually compute
dot and cross products when you're given
them in their component notation see in
the next video